all right welcome to the evening session
of the first day of NBC so my name's
Nick Randolph and I can certainly come
to told bill to roam and hi my name is
puja hummock I'm currently coming from
India and I am a Google developer expert
for flood over from India yes all right
so today hopefully you'll get a bit of a
taste for what flutter is all about and
what we're going to hopefully do by the
end of the session is also taught
through how useful the azure components
or what's there in the world or space
for in Asia and how you can connect your
flutter app to them so we'll go ahead
and get started so we're gonna do is
just before we sort of delve into
flutter or and dart we're gonna give you
a little bit of background of I guess as
to how we came to use flutter so this
isn't technically correct there's a
mistake on this slide so let me see
these are slides gonna behave yes there
we go awesome so this is all about how i
met your flutter okay
and so my experience is somewhat
somewhat different from poojas so I run
it as I mentioned I run a consulting
company and we predominately do
cross-platform apps and so we do apps
the target one or more devices you can
imagine that most of the apps we do is
iOS and Android but actually we do a lot
of Windows stuff as well so we do
Windows desktop Windows you know Xbox
etc and so I guess my background is in
Microsoft ecosystem so of course we use
Ameren and so you know a lot of the apps
that we work in is Ameren forms but one
of the things that we found you know
over the last two years is that the
design philosophy associated with
building mobile apps has changed it used
to be very much hey I want the native
platform controls for my app whereas
these days the branding from you know
the branding department most companies
it you know whips their ice into shape
and basically said no no we don't care
about the platform idiosyncrasies we
actually wanted to look on brand and we
wanted to look perfect and we want to
look pixel perfect with great animations
and so all of a sudden our xamarin forms
developers are going that's a bit of
work mmm not sure I like building
renderers
so when Google came to mark
with with flutter it was an opportunity
to take a look at that and understand
the differences there because from
examine forms perspective we kind of
looked at some of the other
cross-platform technologies and those
didn't really give us a better offering
so for us
flutter cake gave us an offering and
we'll talk a little bit in more detail
exactly why that's the case so anyway
that was my background so I have that
puja yeah
so my addition is a little bit different
and longer I guess so I how many of you
are actually native Android developers
if any great awesome so I've also been
working with Android for more than three
years and I thought that I was in love
with Android but then I think I started
on affair with flutter so it kind of
went like I it was like Android and I
still worry love but flutter and I had
that connection that was a little
different so what went wrong with me and
Android so it was a three years
relationship if you count that chasing
period maybe were trying to get to know
each other
but after a certain point it kind of
became a little too comfortable and that
spark was gone so it came to a point
where I had that phase in my life where
I want you to try out other frameworks
so I thought to myself really this like
one thing do I do this one thing my
entire life so I wanted to try out other
mobile frameworks like react native
ionic I even tried out web because
everyone was talking about it and it was
a big jump for a mobile developer
because I was not just cheating on
Android with other mobile frameworks I
was considering other platforms so but
then it never worked out because I just
could not understand them like all of
them had the same upbringing so so it's
like the soul the personality was so
much similar I realized I think I like
Java better so I joined this company
last year
an Android developer and the boss tells
me so here this is flutter it's new to
town so hang out with it so I started
hanging out with flutter and one thing
led to another and I stopped talking to
Android so I sort of made me sorry
Trident made me realize that how it's
like to be a mobile developer again and
it was exciting it was fun it was like
me again so what is flutter
by the way by the way however I narrated
that stoney it is kind of truth so
flutter is a cross-platform mobile
develop an SDK that lets you build
Android and iOS and now web and desktop
apps through one code base written in
Dart now dot was completely new to me
because like probably nobody had heard
of died before flutter as such but it
was a relief that it was not a J's
framework it was much more easier to
learn and it had this interesting widget
concepts so where widgets are basically
like blocks or components that build the
user interface so in your in our case
the app bar would be a widget the text
on it is a widget the style that you
apply to that text will also be a widget
padding around with a widget the space
is a widget so everyone had a very
interesting concept of widgets where you
could build amazing custom UIs with just
widgets so Nick I guess you were
building some application on flutter so
why don't you tell them about it yeah so
I'm gonna just jump into this code just
quickly and show you a vanilla brand new
app and so rather than trying to
demonstrate the building an entire app
we're gonna I'm gonna show you the very
basics of getting started in vs code
just a side note if you don't like vs
code you can obviously use Android
studio so if you're more familiar with
sort of the Android working and sort of
workflow they've
that all of the tools there in Android
studio as well coming obviously from a
Microsoft centric background I tend to
gravitate towards BS code so let me see
if I can grab a new project so the
really nice thing about the what Google
produces they've they've done the
integration really well into vs code to
the point where you know I can go ahead
and create a new project I can go in DC
demo and give it a folder and off we go
and so one of the things you will find
is it's not just the code editor they've
also integrated a number of the tooling
windows there are some that still sit
outside of vs code so there's what they
call the dart dev tools and so there's
components there that sort of you want
to get into the world of sort of
performance tuning of your app and and
you know looking at the the various
actual runtime behavior of that then
your time you'll actually end up using
those tools if you're using Android
studio a few more of those windows are
actually baked into the actual IDE
itself sorry I'm kind of feeling well
flutter create does its thing so you can
see on the bottom right hand corner the
pop up there's basically saying okay
it's running flutter create so if you
don't like running using the IDE you can
actually drop down to the CLI and just
run flutter basically the idea is really
just a nice editor around the command
line interface for that and that goes
for building and packaging etc as well
so once it's doing that over on the left
hand side you can see the sides you can
see that it started to fill out the
various folders that are going to make
up our application and like with most
other cross-platform technologies you'll
see that there are head sort of all
target folders for iOS and Android
and actually I'm running the master
general so you can actually see that
there's a head project for web as well
if you just go and grab the stable
release you actually you won't see that
right now so 1.9 doesn't have that baked
in but the the the master channels are
the one that they're committing to at
the moment does have the web and so but
the main part of my application is going
to be this main dot dot and so
like with all Grid applications it
starts with a main routine and that's
where it's essentially going to launch
our application so at this point here
where we're looking here we're really
just talking about a dart application
okay so what's this thing called Dart
well as pooja mentioned it's a it's a
it's a new programming language well
it's actually not that new it's it's
been sort of gravitating around and the
sort of the Google space for so almost
about six years or something like that
and actually flood has been around
probably about that length of time as
well because it was an internal Google
project used for a number of their apps
before it got released out to the public
as well
but a data application starts with the
main routine kind of similar to other
programming languages and in this case
we're going to call run app now run apps
basically provided by the flutter SDK
and for the most part you don't need to
worry too much about that other than the
fact that it takes one parameter and
that parameter is can anybody guess what
it is
it's a widget exactly and so here we are
actually launching our application I'm
gonna press f5 because it will take a
minute or two to spin up in the emulator
and but I'll talk through this while
it's doing it so right here we've got my
application or Maya and it is a or it
extends stateless widget okay so we've
got sort of typical oo paradigm top step
happening here where we're extending a
base class in this case it's a stateless
widget there is also a thing called a
stateful widget so as you're managing
the state of your application you are
gonna need to think about whether you're
using a safe or stateless widget but
that's like a two day course in itself
no it's not it's about a half a day
course but it's definitely something
that you need to spend a little bit of
time with so as we delve down into here
part of the next most important thing is
this build method now one of the things
that separates the way flutter works
from virtually every other sort of
technology or sort of cross-platform
technology is the fact that of the way
that it actually does the rendering to
the screen now this came out of the work
that Google did around chrome and rather
than defining the elements on the screen
and then updating them which most other
platforms or frameworks do so in xamarin
you define you know your stuff in zamel
generates the screen layout and then if
you want to update things you either use
data binding or your
manually updating properties on those
element in the flooded world we generate
our widget hierarchy we hand it over and
then the build method gets called again
and we generated a brand new set of
widgets okay and you're thinking oh that
sounds very heavy but no actually what
happened is behind the scenes it doesn't
differential so it kind of worked out
what's changed and only updates those
parts of the screen all right so the
widgets themselves are designed to be
extremely lightweight they're designed
to be generated and disposed of very
quickly okay so you'll the way that this
build method calls is basically every
time I want to make a change to the page
so for example in this case it's a
counter app so we're gonna hit a button
and we're going to increment the counter
every time that runs or every time I hit
that button it's gonna trigger a rebuild
or my widget hierarchy but the only
thing that's changing on the screen is
gonna be that the actual count itself so
that's the only thing that's actually
going to get repainted you don't as a
developer you don't need to worry about
all of that all you need to know is you
need to rebuild the widget hierarchy and
hand it off okay so let's actually see
that in action let me see if I can
minimize this down a little bit move
across and where did I let it go okay so
here's our emulator and there we go
we're incrementing it and the nice thing
you'll notice here is that immediately
we've got that sort of the material look
and feel we've got the fab down the
bottom hand left right hand corner which
is our sort of singular action button
and then we've got things like the app
bar at the top everything you see on the
screen is itself a little widget and so
you know as you started to build out the
layout of your screen you'll actually
think okay well what widget do I need
for this and you'll go off to the widget
hierarchy or the widget index and you'll
find the appropriate thing so as you can
imagine we've got bits of text on the
screen so what's the widget gonna be
it's going to be a text there's a
floating axe agent their action button
it's called a fab so there's going to be
a floating action button widget and so
app bar it's called an app bar widget
right so they've done some really good
you know sensible things with the naming
things I'd quite often when you think
okay well I need a card to display on
the screen
okay you go google flutter card oh look
there's a card widget and so it's very
easy to build up your hierarchy because
of that now let me just quickly set a
breakpoint in here just in case you
didn't believe me that the rebuild gets
called every time
so I'll put a breakpoint just in here
and we'll go ahead and click on there
and so you're nice notice here that
first of all we've got breakpoints that
we can step into we've got some really
nice stuff over here about call stacks
so all the things that you'd expect in
the modern IDE are all there okay enough
about this counter app what we're gonna
do is actually go ahead and actually
have a look at a more realistic app and
one of the things I always struggle with
is keeping a track of the list of things
I'm gonna do okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and actually switch over and we're gonna
have a look at a basic to-do list it's
got essentially a couple of things on
the screen so again you can see this
workflow of making changes on the screen
and actually updating the screen through
this build method okay let me just
minimize that we'll go across to
so this is our simple to do app and go
from the top and so one of the things
that you'll notice here is that again
we've switched away from a state less
widget to a state full widget because
we're now gonna be tracking the some
state ok if I wasn't gonna track any
state so I didn't have a list of tasks I
could get away with it being a stateless
we did ok we are going to track my list
of tasks so I want to make sure that is
a stable widget and what that means is
I've got to have a state object that
goes with it
and so you'll see a quite a common
pattern in plateau where you've got your
actual widget associated with a
corresponding state so you can see here
this is my my homepage widget and the
corresponding state so if you think
about lifecycle of things the state is
something that's going to persist around
where is your actual widgets going to
get regenerated every time something on
the screen changes okay on the on the
right hand side you can see the emulator
running and essentially if I click into
this top thing which is a text field I
can say and press enter and it's gonna
go into my task list okay so what's
going on there so if we take a look at
the structure of this so here we've got
a thing called a scaffold okay so within
our material out we've got the scaffold
the scaffolds useful as a base because
it gives us things like the app bar okay
so the top there you can see that we've
defined an app bar with a title in it
and we've got the body and then if we
wanted to do things like the bottom tab
bar and a tab and things like that those
things are all built into the scaffold
okay the next thing we're going to look
at is the body and because we're going
to be essentially you know we've got two
items there we've got a text field and
we've got a list of items that are going
to appear underneath it
those are laid vertically in a sort of a
column like structure now we just did a
two-day workshop and it was surprising
how long it took people to grasp okay
this is a column because things are
stacked on top of each other or this is
a row because things are stacked across
each other okay it's it sounds a very
basic concept but if you start to think
about your the user experience of your
page and you start to you know put lines
through the various elements and work
out whether things are stacking
vertically or stacking horizontally or a
mix of both you can quite easily
them in two rows and columns now if
you're coming from other technologies
where you're used to like a grid that's
got rows and columns inside it don't
confuse them because they are actually
different these are actually closer to a
stack panel or a stack layout depending
on what technology you come from okay so
within the column we've got obviously
got a children chart for children
property and so we've got two elements
that I make up to make this up called a
text field and at the bottom we've
actually got a nested structure because
instead of just putting our lists in
there or ListView in there we're also
Nesta gating anything called expand and
basically this is hey expand whatever
the child element is to take up the
available space so this came back to
Buddha's point that everything is a
widget so you want to put padding around
something there's a padding widget you
want to do you know control the loud of
something there's going to be a widget
for it so for example centering
something there's a center widget so
you'll end up with this hierarchy of
elements that allow you to define where
things are going to be okay so let me
put a breakpoint in you know a text
field just in here and we're going add
another item in here
obviously one of my to dues okay so you
can see that it's coming here and we're
gonna add this task to the task list and
I can sort of f10 and step through that
it says okay so we can go ahead and
create that it's very very sort of our
paradigm one of the interesting things
here is that you've got this dot
notation essentially that's a cascade so
you can actually set multiple items if
we honor two on there one of the
important things that we need to do at
the end of this method so we've added an
item to the list some point we need to
trigger that build method remember I
said that in order to update things on
the screen we need to we need to rebuild
things well if I was just adding stuff
to the list the frameworks got no idea
that I'm adding stuff to that list it
needs to be told and that's where this
set state comes in so if I let this run
to enter this breakpoint at this point
the screen hasn't updated at that point
we even though we've added it to the
task list hasn't updated if I let this
run now it's gonna add it to the bottom
and then it'll actually call that build
method again okay so set stage is that
trigger to say hey the state of my
objects changed call build and then off
we go and there we have it we have my
beautiful-looking task list and like I
don't know did you just call it
beautiful
okay okay okay what are you gonna do
about it come on they're for making
beautiful applications and you call that
beautiful maybe let's see how we can
make this beautiful so let's see if
mostly we have to do lists so we can
have cards that we were talking about so
let's just add something like a card
widget and so yeah I guess you can see
something like that but what I don't
like is that I hate this white team can
I make this a dog team up so here maybe
I'll just add a dog team and enable the
dark team mode
[Music]
yeah and as you see this will
automatically update the UI just in one
second so now you have a dog team mode
app and maybe I'll do something
regarding the card where I need to add
some padding because I really can't see
anything here so I can add something
like add padding so that's it I just do
not have to do anything and now I have a
padding around the text so this looks
fine now can we do something regarding
the text fields where probably we'll can
add like a prefix I can yeah I need to
add a decoration so I need a decoration
so here I can do a box decoration and
maybe sorry so maybe we do a prefix icon
so hmm so yeah this is why I don't do
life coding but yeah okay well this work
or will this not there is an error hmm
yeah
so we have added some really random I
can write there so I can like so flutter
has a material library of icons and
colors and like you can just get the
icons right here so I if I want to make
this something else it will already be
here so maybe I do something like what
do I do
so like a business because it's a
business to us maybe so I added it right
here and then I can what else can I do
probably I can create a specialist view
here so suppose if I can reorder the
list view right now so something like
reorder bill list view so that's also
right there so instead of all this I
probably have something called a
children which will take a little
general rate and it will take the start
length and hopefully everything in here
can be added so so maybe I'll add it
here
so
so we have a riddle on it which says
that we need something else which is
like what happens on reorder so I have
to add another bottom here which is on
reorder which would say that when the
index is changed what do I do
so here I can just do update items and
that's so now if I run this hopefully I
can reorder my ListView did it work or
did not work so yeah I guess there is
something wrong here so yeah this is
exactly why don't attempt a live coding
this is would be my last life coding
right here okay but yeah so this is how
you could like actually reorder or make
your UI better and as you see that hot
reloading is really really working super
fast here and I can just like change my
UI changes quickly right now if you're
coming from native Android you would
know how much it takes in Gradle
building it actually takes around like
five minutes to actually just update a
change but this was like really quick so
but there is a problem here that we
cannot actually save our data here if I
rerun this app this will actually go
back to zero tasks and honestly I have
just a mobile developer I cannot do
anything regarding back in services and
I want my app to be used in different
devices and have all the data and tasks
reloaded as soon as I opened my app but
I can't I have no knowledge and back in
services I'm pretty certain I can help
you with that
oh can you okay so I reckon we can
probably connect this to a few things in
Azure to make the whole life a little
bit easier so let me just switch back to
these and
see if our slides are going to magically
change okay so as your mobile app now
and the world of Asia as you all are
probably blindly aware it's continued to
evolve so this this isn't a definitive
list by any stretch of the imagination
it's probably a thing that's changing on
a semi daily basis but I guess there's a
few important concepts coming from the
mobile world that it's worth noting the
first one is around DevOps now it's
quite interesting when we when I talk to
developers and you know if you're
working in the web space or api's
there's a mentality in most firms now
that okay they've got to get their dev
dev ops organized they've got to have a
build pipeline they've got to have a
release process even if it's a manual
release process when we have an
automated build etcetera at least I know
when I'm breaking the build and
everyone's broken so at least you've got
the blame there but in the mobile space
it's it seems like people haven't really
cottoned on to that or it's only just
starting to emerge now and I think part
of the fault there is on the tool
vendors because if you're you know
building using say the Microsoft tool
chain then actually in order to do a
build you actually need to install the
tool chain not on a machine in order to
build and so most of the online services
for doing automated builds don't have
that and so the same with the flutter
world I mean if you're gonna do a lot of
build in the cloud you actually need the
flutter SDK installed now the good thing
is that those hurdles are being eroded
most of the the big vendors now actually
have a lot of those SDKs pre-installed
on some of their build build frames so
it's becoming a lot easier so building
distribute highly recommend getting it
set up straightaway we're not actually
gonna go through that process today but
I will show you I build that we do have
set up for a for this particular
application and you can see that you
know we can actually set it up in DevOps
there's a this some third-party
providers like code magic and stuff like
that they'll also have you know those
sort of CI CD pipelines set up the other
sort of aspect that falls into loosely
into DevOps is there is the the notion
of crash reporting and analytics and so
as part of this we'll also show you the
visual studio app Center and one of the
sort of the areas of Microsoft's working
on in that space is the ability to
report crashes and it's actually
relatively easy somebody actually did a
generated a plug-in for flutter to allow
us to connect into that and that gives
us sort of crash reporting and analytics
and stuff like that obviously security
is a big issue for mobile apps you want
to make sure your data is secure
I tend not to work on apps where they
say okay the first we want to create is
a you know a user no password screen
where we're going to be plugging it
straight into the app and I'm thinking
yeah okay so where are you storing those
credentials on the back end and they go
oh well we've got this you know
encrypted database field that we've got
the hash to that we can ungrouped and
like all of a sudden I'm going ya know
so making sure that you pick a good
identity provider or multiple ones of
those I'll show you how to connect or
how we can leverage some of the power of
azure around you know the app service
and actually connecting through through
to things like I should be to see or
address Active Directory or connecting
it through to other third parties is
fairly easy and again there's plugins
available for flutter that people have
worked on to allow that you do that sort
of a warth workflow to allow you to sign
in and that kind of goes part and parcel
with authorization will show you then
I'll show you then how you can connect
the sign-in process to your security on
your services that's mainly all backend
stuff but obviously there's a you know
you need to make changes to your app to
actually walk through that process so
you actually need to call out and make
sure that they are authenticated check
you've got a valid token before you sort
of progress to the next stage and then
of course we actually need to be able to
call our services now in this example
I'm using an app service but you can
apply the same thing to a function okay
and rather than manually coding it so
you know HTTP GET things like that we're
actually going to show you how you can
actually use the swagger to actually you
know generate code that you can then
embed it within your app so it saves you
a whole bunch of typing
okay I mentioned AG DevOps okay so this
is the the plug-in that on studious
developer has built and actually there's
there's two or three of them available
now one which does just a vanilla or
install of the flutter SDK so if you
want to go and write your own sort of
build chain it's that true you can do
that just by incorporating the the
install of the flutter SDK into the
build process and then there's a more
fully pledge one that actually allows
you do a build and release as part of
the pipeline used to do absent how many
people have heard of Visual Studio App
Center okay if you're in the mobile
space it is worth looking at the you
know when I initially put these slides
together a while ago that these are the
main things that they they were doing
they've actually worked into the sort of
the data platform side of things now so
if you're looking at doing end
authentication so if you need somewhere
to you know upscale an app without
having to pay the world in Asia then you
can actually go to view apps and it
gives you those building blocks that you
can quite easily get started with and so
identity and data sort of back-end or
are coming to App Center as well
okay I'm entering as you'd be to see
this is just one of the many other
interview providers that are available
out there it's one of the bigger ones
obviously it backed by Microsoft tend to
the other one we quite often use it is
all 0 there's sort of like one of the
main ones sort of in that sort of
customized workflow space but obviously
if you're working in the sort of the
social space then using you know sign in
with Facebook and Apple ID and things
like that are all part of powerful event
they all kind of work the same way
they'll all work you know open up some
sort of web view get the user signed in
a pass back a token so that your apps
never actually responsible for using
over password information and obviously
the user gives you he has to give grant
your application permission so the nice
thing about LGBT and and what auth0 do
is that they actually provide you with
they can allow you to use multiple
providers okay so you know it's
essentially plug and play basically say
okay well I want to enable Facebook and
I want to know Google and so it gives
you that one staging point and and then
rather than being wholly reliant on
Facebook sort of set of credentials they
then provide you a database the way you
can essentially have some user
information that sits off there so you
can actually capture as part of that
initial signup workflow you can actually
capture you know use it like first name
last name you can attach your address or
you can cut customize it to add in your
own fields you can also define policies
so you can basically you say okay well I
you know the user has to sign in every
30 days or real authenticate we've got a
certain period and the nice thing about
Ezra you see of course it links very
well into App Center
sorry into your regular app services so
that you can use it for authorization so
when you go you will see it today when
we go across to the portal we're
actually going to app service actually
customize the authentication of the
authorization within there okay last of
course is our app service and for this
particular one or is he going to track
our tasks and so I could have actually
probably got away with using a function
for this but for convenience I went with
a it's a donut court app service that
sits in the background
okay so let's connect the dots and see
how this looks so let me switch out now
close
and this is all simple to do okay so so
this is essentially the same donor that
we were walking through earlier but now
we're actually going to connect it to
various parts in Asia so before we do
that let me actually switch over to the
various pieces of Asia we're going to be
talking about so the first one is as
your dev ops as I mentioned those sort
of the build process this was a the
samples were really cool originally
called the world's best flutter wrap
because I couldn't think of a good title
for it to do app anyway so in here we've
got things like we've got a series of
builds and I can go in and actually you
go and edit that and you'll basically be
able to see the the various stages
within those and so essentially we can
manage our whole build pipeline one of
the challenges with mobile app dev is
actually less around the build process
but more around the release process so
in most other sort of technologies if
we're working in the web space most of
the time as part of our release it's a
matter of okay well we've got just got
different configuration for our existing
assets so you know the artifacts from
our build process we're going to change
the configuration for our various
environments socially a little harder
with mobile apps in the sense that you
can't
there is no configuration that gets
packaged with an apk or with a so you
can't actually go ahead and just
reconfigure it like that there are some
some third-party tools that allow you to
essentially pull it apart
replace the file and then reach sign
that verification but that is one of the
challenges of that sort of build and
release process it's also one that I
might add is actually not generally
solved and quite often most people end
up just doing another really another
build as part of that release cycle so
yeah okay so that's the that's build and
release using Azure DevOps I just to
show you that we are actually connecting
to a real service this is our simple to
do service that's going to return us a
list of tasks there's a Jason house
we'll come back to that one in two
seconds because I want to show you how
we can take that and actually generate
the client-side code that we
that we can then use within our
application and then the other one i
wanted to show you was application
insights in sort of question size the
App Center so this is the App Center for
our world's best flutter up and when you
land on the overview page it gives you
basically getting started guide now
there is no flutter option when you go
through setting up an app in App Center
but if you pick the sort of the standard
iOS or the standard Android app it gives
you the necessary information which
actually is buried here it's basically
just the key that you need to get
started so then you go off to the flood
of Lister packages you grab the App
Center one and then you go to your app
and you plug in that bit of code there
now here what you'll see is that we're
actually doing a check based on what
platform type we're targeting and
obviously I haven't put the iOS one in
here but essentially we're picking up
the appropriate App Center ID there
because they do do at the moment they
differentiate between your Android and
iOS app it is a little bit painful
because they're treated as two
independent apps and they haven't got to
the point where they've got a unified
view of that right now
so it does mean you need to
differentiate that in your code one of
the nice things I would add though is if
you actually pull this bit of code out
and put it into a constants file butter
when it does the build process actually
smart enough to realize that it's
building privacy in Android and actually
well actually call out the bits that it
doesn't need as long as you factor it
correctly
okay so the next thing I was just scroll
down to here where we're actually using
our App Center key so here this is where
we're actually calling absented not
starts so it's essentially a static and
we're doing that as part of the
initialization of our app and then
finally when we go down here a little
bit further to the code that we were
looking at earlier where we were adding
a task this is where we're going to
actually track that event and publish it
back up to to App Center so if I go back
up to absent I can come over here and go
to analytics and what you can see here
is that and this is a really low
utilization app but you can see that as
people add tasks you can see that the
events actually appear in this event
list and it also is quite useful let me
see if I break this down it's not going
to let me because it's the dollars a
little bit old now oh no here we go
events and so down here this adding item
is actually the same bit of text that we
actually had here along with the the
item that was added so in this case I
was adding I go test 1 test 2 26 they
they weren't really inventive ideas but
the point is that you can actually
provide backup here information about
the usage of your application just be
careful of privacy requirements here
when you're tracking stuff obviously
don't put any sensitive data into your
analytics information so I mentioned
that we're going to look at the how we
pull data from our service so this is
our service and if I do
swagger we'll see some nicely formatted
this it's got one API called get tasks
but of course the one that I actually
want is this Jason here which is
actually the swagger information that I
can use to generate code now if I go to
app doors where
I can go let's go ahead and create a new
API and let's not create that one
see if we can go ahead and import that
yeah well overwrite the existing one and
here it's basically broken it out the
actually reformat says yeah Mille but
not interested in that particularly but
what we are interested in the ability to
actually code Jen the library for in
this case dart so don't go looking for
flutter because obviously this is a
language library so it's a dart one just
one note if you are going to do this
then there is a thing here where you
need to specify browser client equals
false otherwise you'll get code for dart
to be run in the browser so you know
there's a version of angular called
angular dart that uses dart for the
browser so when you do code gen make
sure you do that and you'll notice that
you can then go ahead and generate the
the dart library from there if I go
ahead and do that it's actually going to
generate a zip file and then I'll go in
anytime and compress it
I've already done that step here so I'm
just going to show you the code over
here under to do this is from you know
here down to here this is all the
generated swagger code and you can drill
in and take a look at how it generates
you a nice wrapper client library for it
and you know generates the corresponding
models that map to to the API etc so
realistically in my code all I end up
needing to do is go okay this is our API
client I'm gonna then call the get
method and it's gonna give me a list of
tasks from server I can then run in my
code I think we're almost there
so what about what did I miss okay so
now we're hitting an endpoint pretty
unsecure didn't really challenge me when
I hit it so let's go and add a little
bit of security to that so to do that I
go back into here into Azure I'm gonna
go down to my authentication block and
I've already pre-configured this with
the information from Azure B to C which
I've gone ahead and set up all I need to
do here is basically say hey if if the
user is nothing Decatur I haven't
presented me with a token what do you
want me to do now right now it's set to
anonymous requests so let me change that
to login with Azure Active Directory hit
save on there
and I'll come back over here and go such
tasks and so what we should see now get
a second to roll through is it you will
see that it's actually a redirector to
login to my company it'll actually
prompt me to sign in so let me just show
you that in code so again there's a
third-party library that allows me to do
off in this case you pass it in a bunch
of information about the as a b2c so
it's things like client ID redirect URI
the discovery URL so basically you
provided that setting information about
which service you want to authenticate
with and then in your code when you're
initializing all we do is essentially
call authorize an exchange code and so
that one line of code it's basically
going to open a web view get the user to
sign in and it'll actually return an
auth code that we can then use within
our application so this is where the
demo gods really kick in let's see
whether it's gonna work yeah so I hope
it depends on what the policies are that
you set up in as your b2c and so
actually what you get back is both you
can get back both an access token and a
refresh token and so obviously that the
access token fairly short live we
typically keep it down to a matter of a
couple of hours the Refresh token
typically you run for 90 days and the
expectation is that it really indicates
and that way you can revoke it and
things like that as well so of course
gods it's still running now I guess one
of the things that there is a bit of an
offset here between the sort of the hot
reload that we saw when we was going
through the various steps of code and
the initial run okay so we can't
unfortunately get away from some of the
build tools that are there for for
Android and iOS so sometimes when you
have to do a restart and there are some
things where you do need to do that so
for example if you're referencing and
bringing in a new package or in some
cases where your
adjusting some of the base elements of
your of your app you may well need to do
a new an actual restart okay and bring
up okay so what you didn't see is that
there is no intro screen on this so of
course it's on startup it's gonna boot
me to the sign-in screen so let me just
do that and no even if you're watching
really quickly this is not my real user
name and password okay and and of course
I didn't take any of your suggestions
around styling my face but those are the
five tasks that are actually coming back
from the yeah that's that's pretty much
it in terms of connecting attach I mean
those are the main pieces that we need
that we typically need to do in an app
from an app perspective what you
obviously then want to do is think about
caching it I'm using things like local
database or local file stores so that
you don't have to keep polling and every
time you run the application the nice
thing is that there are already even
though flutters relatively new there are
already libraries out there that allow
you to do that so whether it be
something where you want to store a
secure string you can use shared
preferences for that if you want to
store files and like Jason serialize
files victory you can do that quite
easily there is also a wrapper for
things like sequel Lite as well so then
you know there's a lot of stuff there
for a fairly new platform it's fairly
well structured out so yeah so now that
we are at the end of the application I
just wanted to ask if was there
something different about our slides
where our slides still there yeah so was
there something different about our
slides do you see something that's weird
about it or not normal no so what you
see is that as we said that the federal
not only runs on Android and iOS but
also runs on web and desktop and you see
that is actually a flatter application
that I'm controlling with my phone so
that's all a flatter application running
from the same project that's running in
my phone and the way
and trust me on this I'm not kidding we
actually finished the projects just like
an hour back finally like how can we
make the audience flow their minds like
okay that's me let's just get rid of all
these slides and Microsoft powerpoints
and all that and this is exactly flutter
web four slides so yeah and of course it
wouldn't be complete without an azure
connection okay so that she runs a
service sitting in the background
unfortunately because flood aware is
still in sort of incubation phase
there's there are certain dependencies
that don't work so for example some of
the i/o space isn't there so I couldn't
use things like signal art which would
have been perfect for this so it is a
bit of a polling mechanism right now but
those those things will go away as them
as the framework matures so the first
sort of version of this you know that we
would have thought of
I always Android easy signal ah there's
already a component there for it like
the example is it's ridiculously simple
to follow but unfortunately the
dependencies are that you know had some
libraries there that aren't there for
photo / web right now and so those are
things that will come to market I mean
it's good to see that it's in the master
channel already which basically means
that they're you know sort of next wave
will you anticipate them being it being
released so anyway I hope you've all
learned something that's it from us feel
free to hang around ask questions I
think we're a little bit early so yeah
should wait yeah
so there is something called platformer
Charles as you see there's a do you have
the vehicle so here you find something
like the Android project is already
there and the iOS project is already
there so there you can actually
communicate with the Android and iOS
projects of to use a native
implementation you can write your Java
or Catalan or Swift or Objective C code
right there though for cameras and
Bluetooth there's already plugins
already where you can go to pub dot dev
where you already have all the libraries
plugins and packages already done for
you but in case you do not have
something already in the market you can
always use half the communication done
right in your project with the platform
channels so yeah so for storage again I
guess there is already on a plugin for
it where you will have to do the storage
SEP the native implementation is
different 400 and iOS because they work
differently simple as that
so even if you have to add a web plug-in
to it the implementation would be
different so you will have to write
three of those code and then all the
results are back to dart files where you
can just like it's like a normal method
call where you like okay get storage
directory that stuff for things like
google has already done all that work
for you but then there are also great
lot of communities who have built a lot
of work for you but again if you still
need something yes you will have to do
the separate implementation for plugins
for any native communication but for
packages which is just dart libraries
then obviously you don't even have to
touch your Android iOS or web folders so
today we use some swagger but I mean
there is also implementations and things
like retrofit so there's a package
called chopper I'm not sure where the
name came from but that's basically a
dart version of retrofit
so you used to that sort of yes you do
there's no escaping that pain no I think
God magic has a solution there yes sorry
so if you don't mind building in the web
yeah you can definitely do that sorry
Jake is like a CI CD tool for flutter
and recently only they actually found
like got released a feature where you
can sign your apps without a my book so
yeah yeah that's not yes so the sort of
the bolt into azure DevOps is very much
a third-party extension for it so in
theory you could do I know that atom
peddler who used to be like a xamarin
forms blogger was actually blogging
about using app centers to do build and
release so he's actually got quite a
comprehensive gut and a guide as to how
to set up a App Center to do that build
and release pipeline because it is a bit
of a pain for everyone yeah yeah so even
even in as your DevOps you don't need to
do that because one of the build agents
is actually a Mac so you can actually
get it done on there so and that in
order to sign things that the Mac is
still the requirement but there are
cloud providers that allow you to do
that so yeah I mean if you if you're if
you want you can generate the build and
sign it and stuff like that just using
the back build agent in Azure DevOps I
guess one thing we would I mean we're
kind of loosely touched on it is that
one of the big differences that is the
rendering here and we didn't mention is
actually based on skier so you know
unlike other platforms that use the
native controls basically the approach
that Google is taken with this is just
give me a blank canvas I'd you know I'm
not interested in these native controls
that don't perform well and we hate
anyhow just give me a blank canvas and
I'm gonna draw everything so they've
actually got they actually use a native
implementation of skier to actually
render everything on the screen so
everything you see you know within the
apps is actually rendered by the by
flutter essentially yep
yep so in terms of rendering there's not
a huge there's not a significant
difference so you the base of your app
you pick either a material app or a
Cupertino F and that basically defines a
look and feel there are some some device
peculiarities so for example on the
ListView when you hit the bottom on
Android you'll get like it's sort of the
indicator at the end and then on iOS you
kind of get that bounce feel completely
controllable you can turn those things
off if you don't want them if you if you
want a very standard look and feel for
your app but they have done some some
tweaks to make it more and more
acceptable because they recognize that I
mean one of the reasons why you want to
do flutter is so that you have the same
uniform experience so there's no point
in going hey I'm gonna do this big
if-then-else at the top of my thing and
go hey here's an material - hey here's a
Cupertino app because you didn't have to
build everything you know you could
reuse logic and stuff like that but you
might as well pick a different framework
if you're gonna do that but no I mean I
think in terms of this the build and
release cycle or the dev cycle there's
not really much difference so long as
you get up and running now obviously I'm
on a Windows machine so they don't have
the equivalent of the remote simulator
that you have in the xamarin world so if
you're gonna do flutter development for
iOS you even you basically need them to
do it on a Mac so it's actually
compiling to native yeah it's actually
compiling to native yep and so the if
you look at the iOS than the Android
code so the you know the Java code
literally there's a main activity that
loads your your flutter blob and that's
the entrance point now you can do other
stuff there if you want in the sort of
the Java code and actually you were
saying some of the apps that you're
working on is actually an Android app
that actually then loads applications
that are working on is like existing
Android and iOS application where we are
inputting flutter into it so it's
actually building from an android as an
android app
then the screens and the interaction and
everything is actually a flutter block
or something so like we have few screens
on Android native and we have few
screens on
flutter itself so even if you do not
want to actually build your application
from scratch in flutter because your
company or your product already you have
already invested your time in it so you
can always do the new features in
flutter by inputting flutter into it
instead of going to the flutter pack so
yeah so it's not so much support for
signal I'll and and this is just for the
web
yeah the flood of the web so again the
support for signal are is actually just
because they've a third-party developer
has created a plugin for it and so
they've got the relevant bits for iOS
and Android there and actually I don't
think it's got any dependencies on those
the the specific to iOS and Android but
it does depend on the dot IO library and
that's one library where the web is
currently different from iOS and Android
I think it's just an implementation
detail that they're trying to iron out
basically
no so that one's actually so one of the
guys who used to work a bill to Rome
actually created that one so it's a I
think it's called flutter Roth but there
are a number of different ones out there
I don't know that any of them are
official as such I think maybe the
Google sign in one might be because by
Google but they the rest of done by
third-party developers one of the bigger
ones James Clancy's done one that
basically caters for nearly all of the
different alts you can possibly think of
so that's quite a popular one as well so
sorry say again
no it's not built-in I imported the
swatch bucket a buckle librarian and use
that this is the the one the services
there is actually a donít called
2.2 service because the swagger support
for that on it for free isn't quite
there yes so in release candidate and
the cogeneration doesn't even for dotnet
doesn't actually work on it right now
from from swagger hub so we've read
we've done that in a new project yeah
that is correct yes so there's no sort
of third party extraction or abstraction
away from that so yeah it's it's a mixed
blessing to be honest because one of the
problems that you'll then have is mixing
business logic with code with you know
the layout and potentially some quite
large layout trees and then you run into
issues okay well I don't want the whole
page to be you know or the whole widget
tree to be rebuilt every time so you
know state management comes a bit of a
challenge and passing that around so
it's definitely something that is it can
be something that you need to come to an
agreement with your team it's how you're
going to handle that and where you're
going to put that kind of logic and how
you're going to factor out you know
classes and widgets and things like that
I mean everyone are used to a fairly
common philosophy of having a class per
file and what you'll find quite quickly
in the sort of the widget world is as
you start to break out your UI to make
it more digestible and sort of easier to
follow you'll end up with a single page
might be broken down into five or ten
widgets but you won't necessarily want
to put those into separate files because
otherwise you'll end up with like
thousands and thousands of files and
chances are that those widgets might
only ever be used on that one page and
you've just moved them out so that it's
easy to sort of work through them and so
you end up in the scenario you know I
mean even things like the widget and the
state you typically keep those in the
same file so that kind of mentality of
moving things into separate files again
you just got to come to an agreement
with your team
it's just good yeah you just have to
like find a good architecture to
actually separate out your UI and your
logic and that's it initially whatever
examples you'll find everything will be
asked actually on the same page but then
again it's just like your choice of
actually having good programming right
there and good architecture skills that
you should just divide everything that
it disposable of course so dart was
definitely not a problem
I mean I'm I still find that sometimes I
get the syntax wrong because I'm used to
see sharp equivalent but I do definitely
particularly because it is you i encode
there's niceties in dart that you don't
have in c-sharp that make it more
suitable for doing UI in code so that
that cascading operator I was talking
about means that you can essentially
declare an object you know dot this dot
that dot this and you can apply them
directly to those objects as part of
that single statement and because the
build routine get you know it's got one
line of code basically so you need to be
able to do that type of thing and it's
got some other things like spreads and
I'm sure there's some options the way it
does optional parameters are quite nice
yeah there's there's a few nice things
to it yeah sorry it does private
variables and private methods yeah so
there's no name spacing you can have
global variables and methods so you run
into the whole web issue of things
colliding but you can do aliasing within
files and stuff like that so it's cause
it's got some very clever things around
compiler optimization so you can have
constant constructors of classes so
essentially if you call the same
constructor with the same parameters
multiple time if it's a comment if a
constant constructor it'll give you
exactly the same object back so there's
some optimizations there we've got a
notion of final variables so you can
assign thing to a variable once and then
if you're trying to reassign it it
complains this there's a lot of kind of
nice things to it
and but the answer is no I didn't find
much issues coming to it occasionally I
forget the syntax but it's easy to look
up the first thing that comes to our
mind would be the hot reloading part was
that it's that quick update thing and
it's not just for UI but it's also for
logic so it's not like you are like
probably like you were talking about one
of the frameworks where you can just
like update the UI really fast but then
here even the logic will be also updated
so like you just like changed your
entire API call and then it will still
just update it right away that was one
killer feature for me because I was
coming from native where we had to like
build like for like five minutes just to
get things done so that was really quick
there other than that I think the widget
concept was really it was difficult at
first but it was really easy later on to
half custom UI because now that
everything what do you give is a widget
what you return is a widget that means
you can do anything with that particular
widget like you can actually build crazy
designs and crazy work over that and
that totally was like like it is our
development work a lot because we can
now do all this
whatever the crazy designs are designers
throw at us we can build that very fast
and logic in itself was not a big deal
since I was already having a native
experience I was not having a problem of
doing platform channels but yeah people
who are coming from not an additional an
order native background will have a
difficulty there because if there are
something plugins are not available they
will have to write it that's one problem
that non-native people will have but I
did not have that so yeah yeah the UI
sort of things not for me it's less
about the way that the widgets work in
terms of the build cycle and things like
that
it's the fact that you know if a
designer comes to you with a design it's
I would probably say it's probably a
third of the time to implement it in
flutter but that's
finger in the air type estimates but
it's significantly easier than thinking
okay well I've got a text field on the
screen how the hell am I gonna get rid
of the hard borders on it and make it
look really good
I mean look in the xamarin world they've
done a lot of niceties around trying to
make it easier so they've got like a
material look and feel to it but then if
you contrast that to the widget gallery
that's a already for flutter like the
simple examples of you know using a card
or using it you know there's there's so
many of the built-in sort of the
material design elements are already
there as we as dedicated widgets now
some of them are actually just
repackages version of other widgets like
in the sense of the card if you look at
the way it's broken out it's basically
just a box with a little bit of text in
it but they've got some nice things
around the way the edgings done they've
done a whole bunch of stuff around the
semantics of it so that you've got
accessibility for it etc like that so
those things that come out of the box is
one of the things I think that actually
sets it apart and you know that they are
light years ahead of where other
platforms are you know whether it's you
know react native different forms to a
degree even in you WP I mean you WP is
super powerful and you can customize to
the nth degree all the elements but you
know in order to build a nice-looking
app you really have to work hard whereas
you know the widget gallery and all of
the options that are available all the
different widgets just make it really
easy so for me that's where the benefit
lies hot reload sure okay it probably
has a better version that xamarin forms
currently does no right now look I come
from a Windows background we've had it
and continue for like the last decade so
hot reload okay it's rebadged but so
what I've had like my Xbox app that I
keep on working on I've had edit and
continue for like since I started
building it three years ago and it's
like well okay so I think get off on
that so much but just the availability
of all of these different widgets and
the ability to customize them really
easily it just takes a lot of the burden
away
from building apps sorry one more yeah
yeah we have yes you know testing also
ha like since we have our like widgets
actually build on clutter so the unit
testing IVs are pretty great there that
we have unit testing we have widget
testing we also have normal integration
testing and then dependency injection
that's there like few options there one
would be the get it package was actually
built by community person in our
community and it's been heavily used by
projects but other than that if you want
compile time like dependency injection
there is something by Google called add
inject that's like there are like
multiple options so you just have to
like know what your project needs it so
even for like a lot of things and you
have multiple option for each of them
so you have to like sit with your team
and actually decide what you want to do
or why why you want to choose one option
so yeah there are multiple options area
you tend to find that that stuff exists
sort of outside a little bit outside the
widget world in the sense of you know if
you're building like service classes and
things like that you'd quite often use
dependency injection to pull those
together for your widgets typically they
don't because you're typically passing
them static values because of the way
the build cycle works so you typically
won't be injecting things into widgets
but maybe into the state you might have
in dependency injection but more it's
the sort of the architecture there is
more service locator than it is actually
a dependency injection but it kind of
they're not too dissimilar